uh have you been shot
yes there was a guy that I didn't know
he had a gun but I just went up to him
we had issues started fighting next
thing you know I feel like my legs get
taken out from under me that's part of
you know living that type of Lifestyle
my name is Johnny Chang former gang
member from the San Gabriel Valley east
side of Los Angeles
was there a hazing process that you had
to go through before joining like how
you say it's hazing it's like a
fraternity ring so you do get jumped in
which which we call it a put on
um you get beat up for sometimes it's
minutes depending on what they're
feeling that day I was only 12 at the
time so oh wow yeah so I I got pretty
beat up what they're trying to do is
establish
um that you you can take a beating
because it's it's part of like gang
culture at least when I grew up when you
were active do you feel like you would
have had a long life the gang life it's
they call it the fast life right so
basically I didn't have any aspirations
to live past 18. I started at 12 so for
me the whole living was about six years
and I did everything I wanted to do
right um drank smoke did drugs whatever
I wanted to do because I knew that we
were kind of on a limited type of time
and we just didn't think anything deeper
than than today or what was in front of
us what is the purpose like of a gang
most came things actually come from a
struggle so where I'm from the gangs
were were formed because there was a lot
of interracial bullying basically
started off as an organization to kind
of protect each other and help each
other but in the end it always gets
corrupted and and this happens across
all Races there's death there's a lot of
loneliness there's a lot of betrayal
impulsive actions shooting somebody just
cuz robbing somebody and hurting other
people like they there's that part did
it give you like a sense of like like
family is that is that why you were
there in the first place absolutely
absolutely my father he was he was an
alcoholic and he was very abusive and
you know he beat my mom he beat me he
beat my brother and I found the gang as
like kind of like a pseudo family like a
a family outside of my actual family
because although my dad was there
physically it wasn't like he was there
emotionally and then when I got in the
gang I really just didn't view them as
my family anymore and I know that sounds
crazy but at one one point my homies my
my brothers were like really more
important to me than my father than my
biological mom and then you're how long
did you do in prison if you don't mind
me asking that sure I went to Youth
Authority at 12. I did four years and
then got out for like a little bit two
months and went back into prison for
like 10 years can you explain the two
second takeoff rule
so the two second takeoff rule whether I
stab you whether I punch you whether I
would jump you whatever I'm going to do
whatever I can Within These two seconds
if I feel disrespected and I don't care
if I catch more time because if you
don't at least in my day everyone would
punk you they would they would take
advantage of you they would take your
food they would take your shoes they
would take everything from you you have
to have this mindset of I'm gonna kill
you first before you kill me so in two
seconds that's the decision you have to
make and they really turned a lot of
children into having like this murderous
spirit and just these unstable people
because that's how why I was it was
really Gladiator school yeah wow
stressed
ah I got it you know I think I have just
what you need our partner for this video
Skylight has a bunch of mindfulness and
spiritual Wellness tools that might help
you out
here try repeating these affirmations to
help you calm down
I'm safe and at peace I'm Not In Harm's
Way
I can choose to respond in a positive
way
my future is bright and my past is
behind me
things are neither good nor bad they
just are
I can feel the stress flowing out of me
as I slow down and focus on my breath
[Music]
I can get through anything with the help
of my higher power
good I'm glad skylight's new app is a
hundred percent free and has a bunch
more tools like that to help you
recenter and guide yourself like guided
meditations affirmations stretching
exercises and more to find more tools to
help you take care of your mind body and
spirit be sure to visit skylight.org or
click the link in our description thanks
so much Skylight for sponsoring this
portion of the episode now let's get
back to the video
if you have opportunities to walk away
uh like sooner there wasn't really a
point where I wanted to walk away to be
honest with you I really felt like this
was the thing that I wanted to Aspire to
be was a gang member that was your
career yeah 100 you know I looked at
prison like University basically like oh
if I get to this prison oh yeah that
means I made it and I know that sounds
Twisted to a lot of people who don't
understand this lifestyle but
essentially like that's all I really had
at that point you know I seen this as
like my hope the lifestyle was hope the
power the you know the respect the money
everything was just hopeful for me did
everybody in the gang assign for a
weapon
oh do they all get a gun yeah or
different or nice I don't know
it depends I'm gonna speak on you know
Asians in general I can't speak on
anybody else at least in my area like
you have to protect yourself some way so
a weapon I would say not necessarily a
gun but you definitely had your brass
knuckles and your shank that was like
you know shoes socks pants shank brass
nothing it was like it was part of your
wardrobe basically right so yeah you do
get assigned those things but most Asian
gangs were usually outnumbered and were
usually smaller yeah we have to defend
ourselves were you ever close to like
committing violence like when you were a
gang member when I was a game member yes
I committed a lot of violence yeah yeah
I think that was all I did honestly it
was very violent I felt like I was a
victim all the time
um I felt like you guys have fathers who
love you and treat you well and I don't
so right then and there I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you I was very vengeful I was
very hateful because I didn't have you
know things that other people so yeah I
committed I reacted through anger and
anger alone bro have you lost any like
close friends like to death and yes yes
I've lost a lot yeah yeah I've lost a
lot not just in the gang but outside of
the gang too I've lost a lot being from
where I was from
drugs were pretty rapid and there's
people who have you know overdosed on
certain drugs there's people who've
completely lost their mind I've lost
friends to you know while in prison
committing suicide things like that so
I've lost a lot of different
in a lot of ways I've lost friends oh
man that sounds really
that sounds really difficult yeah what
was the craziest thing that you
witnessed
hmm
my friend dying in my arms was the the
most craziest thing I would say and
that's because I was supposed to die
that night we had planned to kind of do
something and rob somebody basically and
we plan that you know I'm supposed to go
to the right of the car and he's
supposed to go to the left but when I
step to the right he just stepped in
front of me so naturally I went to the
left and then I hear you know gunshots
ring out and I basically I see my friend
there like dying right so I've been in
shootouts I've been stabbed I've been
all that but
um to actually like see somebody
pass away in front of you is is the
sound it's it's just very very traumatic
how did you
um managed to you know in a way turn
your life around how did you kind of
exit the game that point came to me when
I felt this depression and emptiness
inside of my heart that I could not get
rid of so I assumed oh it's because I'm
in prison of course I'm empty of course
I'm depressed when I get out I'll feel
better but once I got out I still felt
the same if anything I felt more empty
because I was a two-strike felon meaning
no one was going to hire me for violent
crime so I had to go back to trapping or
selling drugs as they call it right and
so when I was doing that I was making
Thirty forty thousand dollars a month
and you know I had a nice place a
penthouse went to Vegas every week did
this and that you know did as much drugs
as I wanted to everything but
um I still felt that emptiness and that
void and then I'll be in a room with you
know a hundred different people from my
neighborhood and I would feel alone like
it's weird like you're you're physically
with people but inside of your heart
it's just like this whole you know it's
just this void my turning point was
around 24 25 years old and and that had
to do a lot with
um finding um God I had that YOLO
lifestyle you know where it's like yeah
well I'm a sinner anyway I keep messing
up so effort I'm just gonna do it that's
how I be it'd be bad for me I'm like man
I already messed up anyways you might as
well add another tally on it exactly
going somewhere exactly dig dig deeper
right you know it's like I recognize
that that was a deception I've been out
since 2014 received it salvation in
2015. I'm now going back to prison since
2023 and I'm you know preaching the
gospel and sharing my testimony like
this and and um yeah bro I feel happy I
don't live that
YOLO lifestyle anymore if you could tell
your younger self one thing before
joining the gang what would it be
I would tell myself don't trust myself
uh because I joined the gang thinking
that I was gonna make money I was going
to have status I was going to have just
everything Respect power of course those
things come with it but I didn't see the
the dark side of things right I mean
what does the world teach you you know
follow your thoughts trust yourself
believe in yourself and that's what I
did and when I did do that I ended up
miserable I ended up depressed I ended
up lonely because I kept living up and
down what I call it is like that roller
coaster lifestyle happy when you're
happy sad when you're sad happy sad
happy sad right it's like an up and down
lifestyle I've learned now not to really
think just for myself because what I
wanted what Johnny wants to do is always
a stubborn you know very like
um you know zero to a hundred like just
crazy impulsive things
um I've learned to kind of put that down
and think about the people think about
you know my family think about my
friends think about my church think
about all the people that it will affect
and that actually stops me from doing
the things that I actually want to do
did you ever find a way of like
forgiving your family like your mom and
dad yeah yeah me and my dad actually
rekindled our relationship you know and
that was only through like I said
through through Christianity I was
taught that
you know that it wasn't my father who
did those things and I was like what
like you don't know that you know you're
you're not my dad right you weren't
there but there was a force inside of my
dad that was dragging him I do remember
my dad saying like hitting my mom and
then saying I'm sorry I'm trying not to
drink but I just keep drinking you know
I recognize that hey there is something
too that's same thing that's dragging me
was also dragging my father the way they
explained it was like a like a builder
built this house and it comes and gets
vandalized we don't blame the person
that built the house we blame the Vandal
right so likewise when I looked at my
dad there was something that hijacked
him I had no longer blamed my dad I
started to see this other thing that was
working in him which we believe is the
evil spirit and when I apologize to my
dad being the victim apologizing to the
aggressor was crazy but he broke down
and he actually said he was sorry and
that's the first time I heard him say
that he loved me that he was sorry we
hugged it out and like years of sadness
just ended right there and we're great
my dad comes church with me we we hang
out I get them food I mean it's a great
thing you know we really Bond now and
it's it's it's amazing honestly that's
that's awesome after you quit the gang
do you still keep in touch with your
brothers
yes yes I I do keep in touch with my
brothers in the beginning you know they
they were like kind of laughing at me of
course they're like oh this guy's a
little Christian boy you know like
what's wrong with him this guy's
different he's peaceful he's not so like
turned up and and crazy but um as they
started to recognize that I was kind of
growing and some of them actually come
to church with me and um you know they
started to see that they also suffer
from emptiness they also suffer from
loneliness depression void and all these
other things and we're taught in in that
gang culture to just mask that and never
show that but um you know I I kind of am
the person who allows people to be
vulnerable and and be themselves you
know and um it's a it's a much better
relationship now than it was actually
even when I first joined the gang so
yeah
amazing I'm really glad to hear that for
you
um and then on a more lighthearted note
um what do you like to do for fun bro
I'm like an old soul honestly I like to
fish I know that's crazy okay yeah
that's cool I like to I like to fish and
I like to eat fish too so it's like a
double you know